alrighty
i see that you're hungry
hello
hello
hello
[Music]
good morning
we're in the tammy ride here's casey
driving
and we actually have
uh some special guests in the car here
we have
caesar and sylvia and their baby adrian
and isaac so i actually went to high
school with sylvia isn't that crazy i
went to high school with her so it's
been really nice hanging out with her
and her beautiful family so today we're
actually heading over to solvang and
it's a tiny little town that's like i
guess like kind of like a dutch town
it's like further north so we're driving
up from l.a there's also uh santa
barbara in the area so once we've
finished the whole thing then we're
gonna check out that area but yeah we
have an adventure today you guys are
coming along i've seen pictures of soul
bang and it always looks so cool i feel
like we're in europe yeah exactly they
have like a little windmill and
everything yeah i got finally dressed up
to go to solvang
nice
or slacks today instead of my joggers
that i've been wearing for like the last
two years that's true
yeah did my hair oh speaking of wardrobe
i actually found it very difficult to
find something to wear today i'm wearing
like these yoga pants
like nothing spits me anymore
everything's really tight i need to go
shopping already
all right so we finally made it after a
three hour ride how do you feel uh
pretty good oh
on your tippy toes oh my god you're
really that tall yeah oh
that's crazy i'm not used to seeing you
this tall even though we live together
like this i remember i know remember we
hold hands give your hand
you're like that no
no look at me you're taller than me dude
i could
i actually have to lean in to rest my
chin remember you've always wanted to do
that and you'd be on your tippy toes to
do it and now you can actually do it
without i could kind of have the legs
yeah that's crazy but yeah so we made it
to solvang let's see let's see what this
little town has got to offer you could
already see like the little buildings
it's kind of far away to show you but
the buildings kind of have like that
dutch um
what is it like outlining kind of thing
look you can see it over there way over
there you see that building it's like
we're in a disney movie like uh snow
white or something oh yeah is it is that
dutch like one of them has to be touched
right now it does kind of look like that
yeah you got adrian you're nice and
awake
[Music]
his eyes he's like dad can you make this
stop please
cutie he's tired of the three-hour car
right
let's watch a little bit
oh my god your chunk litha is so cute
cute little chunkless
look at you go dude you're not even a
year old and you're walking
that's amazing he's like leave me alone
lady i don't really know you
so how was the ride was it comfortable
because this is the first time we have a
car seat in the new family car so you
guys are testing it out for us and then
bringing
you could like lean back um the seats
and then there's space in the middle to
really expand your feet i loved it yay
i'm glad you guys are comfortable
because yeah we got to test out
the whole shebang here every single seat
was filled
so
casey's happy he gets to test out his
baby
[Music]
this looks like it's a small world
after all
[Music]
means it's danish for sunny fields i
found it in 1911. interesting
1911 oh my gosh
that's oh
a hundred
and 10 years old
i'm like what's that yeah that's right
it is
all right so we're in seoul bang having
a good day how's baby's day going today
baby is baby
it is baby i don't know baby's kind of
squished in these yoga pants that don't
really fit me that well
yoga pants yeah i gotta buy some clothes
yeah at least they weren't being
squished more by the seat belt yes all
the the good old trusty seat belt thanks
to daddy yeah yeah i call it the or
baby's first car seat yeah which isn't
even a car seat just yet but it is
yeah and it's for the baby
yeah
[Music]
ice cream pretty good that's heartbreak
dutch ice cream tastes to you dutch
american melting it's supposed to be a
pistachio it doesn't taste like
pistachio at all
we got dripped
i think it's vanilla
with pistachio nuts i think it's
attached
it is vanilla so sylvia got strawberry
uh-huh and you had or you had gotten me
a vanilla one good so then i went back i
was like oh my gosh she wanted flavors i
didn't know that there was more flavors
and then i saw possession i'm like okay
pistachio is the one and i regret it i
wish i would have gone strawberry it's
just vanilla with pistachios well we're
in the same boat because i got the same
pistachio what'd you get baby
cookie dough oh is it good whenever they
have cookie dough always get it
nice is it good is it vanilla with
cookie dough in it
no it's actually cookie dough flavor
[Music]
all right so i was saying earlier
probably some disney princess like
culture here and uh look at what he
found that's the little mermaid it looks
like she it just has um the section just
has legs but if you go around you see
the fin
[Music]
so we came to feed ostriches is that how
you say plural emus australi
[Laughter]
first time
so apparently slovang is known for
having ostriches they have a whole
petting zoo here so we're gonna feed
some ostriches and pet them are we
petting them no we're not petting them
okay don't don't do that
look at it look at that
oh my goodness it looks like i'm looking
at a dinosaur yes we like to bite it's
done
that's a velociraptor that's unreal
hi dude
oh my god
oh he's got his mouth open hungry
[Music]
you made a mess there dude
you're only eating wood you know that
he's just only eating i like licking it
clean
it's wood looking delicious what are you
doing you broken
oh it's like a baby
oh true doesn't know better
he's trying to bite you
he's going down with me
[Music]
there's a hole here
i got sucked in like jurassic park
[Music]
[Music]
right
i'm like you flapping your wings
17 weeks today you guys
well yesterday but
[Music]
it's some
dutch word that i can't pronounce so
they just call it the house favorite
there we go
can't go wrong with that i like the way
yours looks you were saying this looks
like dutch asians yes asian food friday
as we all know asian food we all love
putting like the fried egg on top of
anything over rice over meat and we got
the wiener schnitzel
[Music]
all right so now we're heading to santa
barbara
santa barbara we're done with solving it
was nice and fun and memorable and
pretty quaint
quaint adventure and then we have the
baby music playing in the background
here because
little baby adrian
is fighting off his nap but it's
actually been a pretty good
practice for us hearing a parent a new a
more recent parent
um in action because i am practically
like i'm a newbie i totally forgot
everything
sylvia is giving me the rundown of
what to expect now like that here it
goes
i actually appreciate it though because
i'm like
that's what that was
that's true i remember that i totally
forgot that you can flash the other
opposite traffic to let them know that
there's a cop ahead
someone just did it to me and i was like
oh there's a copperhead and sure enough
there's a cop oh
that was a cop yeah i was like what are
you talking about sometimes i'm like i
wish i could go back and like hey thank
you buddy that's driving your office
away that's far away that's never
happened to me really so i was so
confused right now when you were staying
honest it's meaningless like roads like
this when it's like small enough and
like they can go sometimes i see people
flashing like oh heads up there's a cop
oh that's nice now i know
look at
that it
i totally missed it
[Music]
we're going off-roading
on the pier
because it's technically a road still
it's wood
we're going off landing off landing
on the pier
can't do this in santa monica though
true
i can't even see it anymore baby's gone
no
come out the place you're about to play
over here baby i'm so glad i brought
this cause i brought a different jacket
i'm like it's not gonna be that cold
but knowing myself i'm better about this
guy true
[Music]
so casey was just like
what the heck this is weird shouldn't
the sun be setting
that way because that's where the water
is but the sun is setting that way
where there's like a hill and mountains
yeah there's land but then we look at
the floor
there's a compass and it says west is
this way so the sun wasn't wrong he was
like you know what the sun decided to
sit on the wrong
side huh yes it did you were like no
this is wrong you think the sun never
makes errors but the sun made an
totally wrong
[Music]
oh i dare you you will not get a
replacement
i'm holding on with dear life i dare you
to lose one finger like like do this no
do the pinky do the pinky
[Laughter]
[Music]